this is the practice of empathy that  have wish struggling to communicate to  someone if it's struggling to help  someone be at their natural best I'm  tired of people saying to me how do I  get the best out of my people really  that's what you want there like a towel  just lingam how can I get the most out  of them know how do I help my people be  at their natural best right we're not  asking these questions we are not  practicing empathy we have to start by  practicing empathy and relate to what  they may be going through and it will  profoundly change the decisions we make  it will profoundly change the way we see  the world  [Music]  [Music]